an illegal refugee camp near the town of
velika kladusa
in northern bosnia abdellah a
palestinian
is back after being forcibly deported
from croatia by the border patrol
where they deport you in this
area voluntary aid worker 49 year old
yasmina hoshide
came across abdullah during her evening
rounds now she's trying to supply him
with bare essentials
i have a tent here but i
i don't have a sleeping bag
yes mina says she sometimes feels bad
that she can't do more for them
during the day she works in a bosnian
government office
but after leaving her office she heads
out as a volunteer to help the refugees
for the past year yasmina has gone
shopping for them every day
paying with donations or out of her own
pocket
buying rice oil and sometimes meat
then she packs donated shoes jackets and
pants and bags
and labels them with the mobile phone
numbers of refugees she's in contact
with
that way she can be sure each one has
received what they need most
my two daughters study one is in
austria other is germany so if they
can have a chance for better
life why other people can't help
soon afterwards yasmina is on her way to
the first stop of the evening
this is chimney factory
we first got there
can you help me please
hello hi
hello hello hi hi uh
here is two three groups about a dozen
young men
most of them algerians have found
shelter here
she's cute what is his name
sometimes it's very hard
i do what i can do maybe it's not enough
but i'm just human like everybody else
hundreds of migrants are living in
conditions like this in bosnia
without the help of people like yasmina
life would be impossible
but for the volunteers themselves the
situation in bosnia is becoming
increasingly risky
we're doing everything very quiet and
not to challenge anybody okay in this
situation
i think that is better i'm very ashamed
because
some things what uh doing here people
a lot of bad things happen yasmina
hoshidich and other bosnians are
organizing a volunteer aid group
and hope to get it registered without
official permission says the canton's
interior minister nemanj
it's actually illegal to render any
assistance to refugees
bosnians who do so can be charged
foreigners
deported if we discover foreign citizens
working without a permit in bosnia and
herzegovina
they will be deported and banned from
entering bosnia for a certain period
in accordance with our laws
foreign aid workers have complained
about the difficulties of getting
officially registered
and even then the work of refugee aid
organizations as here in lieber is
strictly regulated
the bosnian authorities also want to see
all the migrants
housed in camps like the one in lipa
this is one reason for the hard line
taken against volunteers like yasmina
who visit illegal camps like this one in
the forest
but for the refugees here she's often
the last hope
someone give food someone give clothes
shoes everything
that's why something feels good but our
men want to go
forward go italy but their chances of
getting there are slim
they will probably have to hold out here
for months
i want that they feel welcome here but
probably they not fail here
they don't have a place for shower they
don't have place for
washing for cooking as long as they
remain here
yasmina hoshidic intends to keep coming
by
every evening to help as best as she can